[Música]
é eu trouxe uma cola ali porque eu ia
fazer a minha palestra é lida a primeira
vez que o palestra
mesmo tendo 43 anos agradecer a
oportunidade como a gente falou aqui no
início eu vou pegar já que o controle
não é que vai ser me ajudar mas como
falou como o introdutor falou é eu hoje
sou o sócio fundador da multi é uma
empresa que implanta infraestrutura
urbana esportiva em várias cidades do
brasil e serviços conectados a ela e é
desculpa a o tema da palestra ter se
iniciado em inglês mas é basicamente o
que eu vou trazer aqui de insight é que
a gente vai falar um pouco dos mártires
mas o que mais além de seis martin uma
cidade pode ter para ser uma cidade
agradável para se viver
e aí eu estou bem feliz de estar fazendo
a cidade aqui porque eu com um arapuan
nós implantamos a uns dois anos atrás
uma fábrica escola hoje há muita tensão
indústria aqui dentro e produz
equipamentos que hoje vão pro brasil
todo e até hoje já também do exterior
aqui no início do ano o que é bem legal
então todo mundo já ouviu falar né diz
martin siri e esse conceito é uma
tendência mundial que existe atualmente
uma corrida em várias áreas de
conhecimento para se desenvolver
soluções e tecnologias para melhorar as
cidades mas é pra desenvolver e
implantar essas tecnologias no espaço
urbano
eu trabalho muito com implantação de
projetos em áreas públicas
a gente sabe que são necessárias
permissões para instalar tanta
tecnologia como as plataformas o que não
é nada fácil então a maioria dos
benefícios dessas novas tecnologias dos
martírios estão vindo vão vir lá no
futuro e mesmo assim vai ser necessário
um esforço muito grande de implantação e
articulação é hoje quando você olha para
o universo no mundo todo
você percebe que o que está sendo
estudado de marte se nos congressos ou
mesmo quando você abre o site de
empresas que mais na frente você
tá são temas como mobilidade segurança
moradia sustentabilidade educação health
care
então se o como o carro vai se mover na
cidade se você vai apagar o sinal é
eletronicamente se vai identificar que o
sinal não está funcionando e vai receber
um chamado para manutenção automático e
aí tem milhares de empresas pelo mundo
todo desenvolvendo tecnologias para
essas áreas para deixar as cidades mais
automáticas e e todas interconectadas e
aí eu faço uma questão trago aqui uma
reflexão pra gente se isso esses temas
são suficientes de se tratar
será que é só isso a gente pode e além
disso então a minha resposta é
claramente é eu é não a gente sabe que
tem muito mais a ser tratado
eu sou fã de uma revista e monaco que eu
leio já os 10 anos e e muito eu fico até
feliz que eu vejo que tudo que essa
revista defende mostra ela tem uma
conferência anual das melhores cidades
para se morar é que as melhores cidades
para se morar onde as pessoas mais
gostam são aquelas que tratam bem seus
espaços urbanos
entre os prédios são as cidades que
tratam bem seus parques são as cidades
que tratam bem suas praias e tratam bem
suas praças levando as pessoas até elas
porque hoje a gente defende la empresa
que uma cidade não se faz dentro dos
prédios quem mora lá dentro no trabalho
estressante em frente ao computador não
ela se diz na inter relação entre as
pessoas seja quando você vai a uma
cerveja na beira de um lago em munique
seja quando você vai fazer uma atividade
uma aula coletiva de yoga na beira da
praia ou você vai na academia você vai
correr junto com um amigo tem uma
infinidade de momento seu filho jogar
bola seu cachorro que você pode fazer
nesses espaços
e aí tem uma foto até de munique onde
mostra um parque e todas elas depois
quem tiver curiosidade pode ir lá
conhecer essa lista da cidade de um
outro conceito que eu vou trazer pra cá
que a gente identificou numa empresa de
consultoria the future
hebe que é o de brinde decidir isso na
verdade o que está acontecendo hoje nas
grandes companhias de tecnologia é que
elas estão desenvolvendo uma série de
serviços e aí o google tem o site uol
clebes você entra no site ver um monte
de diárias de conhecimento
a amazon tem área dela a microsoft ea
ibm no futuro você vai escolher morar
numa cidade provavelmente igual você
escolhe entre android e o s
você vai pensar sim eu quero morar na
cidade há mais um porque ela tem esse
serviço eu gosto disso e vai morar numa
cidade google o rio de janeiro vai
adotar a plataforma do o o da outra arma
mas é incrível de se pensar mas é isso
que vai acontecer
e pra a além das tecnologias o que a
gente defende é que a gente tem que
colocar a comunidade em primeiro lugar
aí eu volto no tema é das praias praças
mas colocando as pessoas em primeiro
lugar e pensando como elas vão viver
nesse espaço urbano não pensando como
foi era antigamente onde você pensava
como que o carro e ambos se locomover
onde o prédio está lá não é muito mais
do que isso e você tem que no detalhe do
ser humano né a gente trouxe esse
desafio de ir além da mobilidade além da
sustentabilidade mas também transformar
a cidade numa cidade homicídios porque a
gente a mud antigamente nosso slogan era
brand building e municípios construindo
cidades saudáveis
recentemente a gente mudou para a vida
lá fora em detalhes o conceito trazendo
o o o ser humano ali para o centro ainda
mas o que a gente faz nesses anos todos
é é transformar a cidade à comunidade ea
vida das pessoas que moram lá em uma
cidade mais saudável isso é muito ao
saber que quando a gente apresenta isso
é lá fora
isso é ação com a cge a estação que é
uma patente nossa seja academia ao ar
livre e gratuita que houve há 20 anos na
califórnia e lá era paga eu resolvi
fazer uma academia gratuita é
êêê onde o com patrocinadores a gente
oferece esse serviço à população então a
gente acredita que dessa forma a gente
vai além de ser um smart né
e como que a gente resolveu essa
situação como que a mud encontrou uma
solução eu diria que eu já estou no meu
quarto modelo de negócio da empresa eu
comecei como uma indústria vendendo
equipamento batia na porta de
prefeituras e o convence eles a
implantar academias eles operavam
depois eu descobri que quando eles
operavam era muito ruim e eu comecei a
propor locação e serviços para
patrocinadores ou prefeituras
então a gente tinha uma em uma
continuidade do serviço a garantia da
entrega
o terceiro modelo de negócio foi quando
a gente inseriu o out of home
a gente passou a concorrer quase com a
clear channel ou com uma jc de cor onde
você tem ali através da mídia o
financiamento da infraestrutura que a
gente coloca na cidade e agora a gente
está indo para o quarto modelo onde a
gente vai trazer novas soluções de
tecnologia
a gente é na área de smartphones para se
somar com que a gente já fazia de
wellness de de saúde de fitness e eu ea
mídia que a gente tem nossos
equipamentos
então a gente através da intercessão
desses três indústrias a gente construiu
uma coisa única que consegue ajudar uma
cidade ser mais saudável
aqui tem um algumas fotos de tudo que a
gente faz é no brasil todo hoje a gente
atua em sete capitais a gente está em
goiânia brasília rio são paulo curitiba
é florianópolis é temos uma filial na
frança
estamos com agora finalizando um
contrato com a prefeitura de los angeles
para implantar uma academia ao ar livre
essa tem um parente é muito engraçado
porque a 21 em 95 eu fui fazer um
campeonato para americano de jiu jitsu e
aí a minha vida toda a relação é com
judith eu vi aquela academia em verniz
falei porque coisa legal mas será que
não cabe lá no rio e em 99 a gente
montou um projeto piloto quando estava
na faculdade de uma academia ao ar livre
com equipamentos e assassino
acho que a gente desenhou e com um
atendimento gratuito com o professor
manuel coutinho da rj desenvolvendo
porque a gente não tinha aqui no brasil
esse atendimento é gratuito né e aí foi
um sucesso o projeto da etnia hoje 20
anos depois
ontem a prefeitura de los angeles ganhou
o contrato para a empresa nossa lá nos
estados unidos assinando a reforma da
academia que me inspirou e 95 então
provavelmente em janeiro fevereiro a
academia de los angeles que me inspirou
a 20 anos atrás vai receber a tecnologia
e equipamentos vindos do brasil pra
fazer essa reforma uma volta e aí
pensando nem é então hoje a gente
definir o que a gente faz também como um
ecossistema onde onde tem todas essas
fácil a gente tem academias ao ar livre
a gente tem estações de ginástica nós
temos aulas coletivas essas aulas são
encontradas através de um aplicativo
então a tecnologia já está embarcada aí
que facilita é a a marcação de aula o
aluno saber se a aula foi cancelada se
não foi a gente tem é também um trainee
trox pelo brasil todo que são
equipamentos são vans ou caminhões
cheios de equipamentos opcionais aí pra
yoga e esses equipamentos vão até as
mais diversas localidades aqui no rio a
gente tem em copacabana tem ali perto da
subida ele daniel maia e aí acontecem as
aulas nos locais com o apoio desses
caminhões e sempre uma coisa que a gente
também é destaca é que a entrega da
cidade é mais saudável ela é baseada na
promoção e de encontro entre si
então é com as pessoas se relacionam
então ali juntas seja indo até uma
orientação ou numa aula coletiva ou
participando de uma de uma aula de yoga
com 60 e 70 pessoas que acontece todo
dia aqui em são paulo florianópolis e se
contra essa troca de energia que que nos
motiva a a a colocar a empresa toda
nessa direção é é a professora nossa de
até você realizou meu sonho da minha
vida porque eu dava aula lhe paga na
urca para 34 por dia hoje eu sou paga
pra dar aula no arpoador ou no leblon e
recebeu 70 e 80 pessoas praça e trocando
energia com essas pessoas até costume a
palavra empresa que essa energia de
alguma forma volta e parece que as
coisas sempre vão crescendo e dando
certo lá pra gente porque são milhares
centenas de milhares de pessoas usando
tudo isso é em conjunto né
aqui isso aqui foi um evento que a gente
fez lá no museu do amanhã onde a gente
marcou colocou todo mundo de nova
escondido e levou lá pra fazer uma aula
de ginástica
então o ecossistema da mud base em
quatro eixos e rodas você tem os
patrocinadores que pagam para ter sua
marca vinculada aos valores de saúde
esporte você tem o governo que dá a
permissão pra gente atua nas áreas
públicas e apoia é a gente tem os
professores que ou trabalham nas aulas e
nos projetos que a gente dá o usam as a
os projetos seja uma estação para dar
aula hoje na praia de para mim né e nas
praias do rio na ilha do governador e
tudo os professores usam essas estações
como base de treinamento não é um local
para eles empreenderem e poderem ter
alunos pagos e você tem os usuários que
tanto podem contratar esses professores
como também participam dessa
infraestrutura que a gente oferece é com
o patrocínio das empresas hoje o agente
tem um banco que é o maior patrocinador
nosso alguns números que a gente do
nosso impacto
são mais de de 300 mil pessoas que usam
as estações as academias as aulas são
600 são mais são 520 estações de
ginástica pelo brasil todo e mais de 100
academia essas academias ao ar livre até
as academias que a gente implantou no
início da empresa ea gente tem mais de
150 professores atuando nesses projetos
então é ea tecnologia entra ali quando
traz exatamente ajudando a organizar
toda ser o sistema hoje a gente tem
alguns projetos em desenvolvimento já
diz marcia de tem sensores mas está
acho que identifica quem chega reconhece
o aluno a gente desenvolvendo por
exemplo balanças de bioimpedância pra
você disponibilizar nos espaços onde
você vai registrar a tirar o peso ver
com a tendência está engordando e
emagrecendo registra no aplicativo e
outras coisas que estão em
desenvolvimento e que vão deixar todo
esse ecossistema ainda mais sofisticado
é então mas allen também do esporte a
gente pode lembrar que uma cidade para
ser mais saudável
a gente pode ter outras atividades como
comunitárias hortas as pessoas
desenvolvendo feiras nos espaços urbanos
praticando outros esportes comendo bem
sendo bem educada aqui a faculdade
a união pode contribuir muito junto é
dessa educação de como disseminar esses
hábitos saudáveis população eu sou um
exemplo perdi mesmo trabalhando eu perdi
10 quilos últimos seis meses
simplesmente cortando açúcar massa e
umas coisas então levar isso à população
muito legal e ter mais segurança e
mobilidade
então agora a gente está desenvolvendo
com algumas escolas que já tem uma área
de pesquisa nessa área é um equipamento
é uma área de pesquisa onde no futuro o
que eu vejo é que a gente vai poder
entregar serviços através de algoritmos
onde você vai entender quem é o usuário
então vou para escrever sua série e e
poder te dizer ao se você está em casa
vai fazer isso você tá na rua você fazer
que está na estação se você tem um
acessório e através de visão
computacional é você vai filmar então
por exemplo levantando ombro errado
tirei o calcanhar do chão o computador
processa em real time que manda uma
mensagem de voz pro pelo teu celular pra
você receber o professor de educação
física vai continuar sendo muito
importante na promoção das aulas no
acompanhamento pessoal mas com
tecnologia gente acredita que chegou o
ubs sem a gente fazer uma comparação bem
assim sem motorista gente vai conseguir
levar de centena de milhares talvez
milhões de pessoas porque a gente vai
conseguir alcançar ainda mais pessoas
sendo atendidas e recebendo essas
informações dessas tecnologias
disponíveis
queria deixar uma mensagem que tudo isso
é parecer uma loucura atrás quando eu
comecei mas com muito amor e dedicação a
gente vê que o impacto de uma idéia da
faculdade pode chegara a milhões de
pessoas pelo mundo
é isso obrigado